JULY THIRD HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
I AND WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN AS
WELL ACTUALLY I GUESS WE'LL GIVE
IT.
WE GIVE OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES -- THREE MORE MINUTES
AND THEN WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE
.
GOOD MORNING ARE WE ARE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE ARE CURRENTLY WAY
TEEN.
FOR AUTHORS AS TO AUTHORS IF YOU
COULD PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO
THE ACCOUNTABILITY HEARING
THANKS
WHAT CAN SENATOR GLAZER
THANK YOU.
I WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
THAN WITH ODD FILE ITEMS SIX SB.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN IT'S CATCHING
MY BREATH GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
AT OUR MORNING EXERCISE HERE IN
THE CAPITAL ON THE STAIRS SAYS I
NEED TO DO MORE CARDIO.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH BY STAFF FINE
TO TAKE A AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN THE BILL.
THAT'S BEFORE YOU. SEVEN SIX
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKING RACK.
THE CELEBRATION OF THE CARNEGIE
STATE VEHICLE RECREATIONAL AREA.
KNOWN AS THE ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSION FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES.
IF THE DEPARTMENT DETERMINES
IT'S IN THE PUBLIC AT PUBLIX
INTEREST.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A PLAN
TO EXPAND CARNEGIE. FOR
RECREATION USE WAS APPROVED
WHICH LED TO BROAD LOCAL
OPPOSITION.
HI THIS IS A DISTRICT ISSUE FOR
ME THIS AREA IS LOCATED IN MY
DISTRICT.
AS WELL AS A DISTRICT OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REBEKAH BAUER K.
HAND WHICH IS WHY OUR JOINT
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL.
BY THE PROJECT FOR IT TO EXPAND
THIS OFF ROAD VEHICLE PARK AS I
MENTIONED -- HIS BROAD LOT LOCAL
OPPOSITION IT'S CURRENTLY IN
LITIGATION.
I AND INCLUDES THE IN OPPOSITION
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA.
AND THEIR CHALLENGING THE SEQUEL
APPROVALS OF THE PROJECT.
A LARGE DELEGATION OF BAY AREA
CAUCUS MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND SENATORS.
HAVE JOIN WITH ME IN ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER SELLING
THIS EXPANSION AREA.
RECOUPING THE FUNDS AND
INVESTING FROM A SITUATION
THAT'S BEEN MIRED IN CONTROVERSY
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SAID THAT EVEN
IF THEY WANTED TO SELL THE LAND --
WE WOULD NEED LEGISLATION TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN WHICH IS WHY
I'M HERE TODAY AND THE BILL IS
BEFORE YOU TODAY -- THIS BILL
MEASURE SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
AGENCIES.
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM A FEW OF
THEM IN A MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT
THE PRISTINE H. OF THE LAND
THAT'S IN QUESTION -- THAT HAS --
SUPPORT DEATH FROM THE THE THE
REGION TEND AND AND MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS AND AND I WANT TO
JUST.
CLOSE ON THIS POINT THAT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T MANDATE
ANYTHING IT PROVIDES AN OPTION
FOR THE DEPARTMENT IF THEY
DETERMINE IT'S IN THEIR BEST
INTEREST. TO TO SELL THE LAND OP
FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
I HAD SOME WONDERFUL WITNESSES
HERE TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL --
THANK YOU OF THANK YOU CHAIR --
MY NAME IS KATHERINE PHILLIPS
I'M WITH SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
THIS PROPERTY IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT AND THIS ISN'T ABOUT
STOPPING IN -- H. B. PARK THIS
IS ABOUT PROTECTING A VERY
SPECIAL IMPORTANT PROPERTY THAT
HAS BEEN PART OF THE NATURAL
HISTORY AND NATURAL HISTORY A
RESEARCH IN CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES.
JOHN YOUR THE FOUNDER OF SIERRA
CLUB WHO FOUNDED IN -- EIGHTEEN
NINETY TWO WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO HAS STUDIED THIS THIS.
PARTICULAR PROPERTY THIS TOUGH A
PARK AREA IT'S WHERE MULTIPLE
BIOTIC REGION'S COME TOGETHER A
STATEMENT BY MORE THAN FORTY BY
FORTY FIVE SCIENTISTS ABOUT THE
ECOLOGICAL VALUE OF THIS
PROPERTY.
OF THAT WAS SIGNED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NOTED THAT THERE WERE --
FORTY TWO SPECIAL STATUS
WILDLIFE SPECIES EIGHT FEDERALLY
OR STATE LISTED IN CANDIDATES
SPECIES THIRTEEN SPECIAL STATUS
IN TWENTY EIGHT LOCALLY RARE
PLANT SPECIES SEVENTH.
SENSITIVE VEGETATION COMMUNITIES
THERE HAVE BEEN -- RESEARCHERS
COMING FROM UC BERKELEY FOR
DECADES BRINGING THEIR GRADUATE
STUDENTS OR THEMSELVES TO
RESEARCH AT THIS AREA.
NOW AT THE TIME OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WE NEED SPECIAL REFUGIA
FOR SPECIES -- THIS THIS MORE
THAN EVER MORE THAN EVEN WHEN IT
WAS ACQUIRED IN THEIR EARLY
EARLY NINETIES THIS MORE THAN
EVER IS A TIME WHEN WE NEED TO
PROTECT THIS AREA.
TURN IT INTO A PASSIVE PARK THAT --
WHERE THERE'S LESS OPPORTUNITY --
FOR SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE TO THE
SPECIES AND TO THE TO THIS TO
THE THESE BUYOUT BIOTIC.
SYSTEMS THERE.
THANK YOU AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT WITNESS WE'RE JUST
GONNA PAUSE SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PT
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT.
PATTERSON PATTERSON PRESIDENT
BURKE [inaudible]
LACKEY MEDINA.
MEDINA PRESENT QUIRK SILVA SMITH
SMITH PRESENT.
GREAT THANK YOU IF YOU COULD.
PLEASE CARRY ON A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EXCUSE MY BACK ON MY NAME'S BETH
SOURCE BURKE AND I'M WITH THE
EAST BAY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY.
TO SAVE TIME I'M GOING TO REFER
TO THE ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSIONARY AS TESLA.
PRESERVING TESLA IS A LOCAL
PRESERVATION PRIORITY THAT'S WHY
THERE'S OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AGENCIES
NATIVE AMERICAN GROUPS RANCHERS
CITIZENS AND CONSERVATIONISTS
FOR THIS BILL.
TEST THE WAS PURCHASED -- FOR H.
B. USE BUT WITHOUT AN
ACQUISITION E. I. R..
AN ACQUISITION E. I. R. WOULD
HAVE REVEALED THE PLACE SO
SPECIAL THAT IT MEETS THE
DESCRIPTIONS OF BOTH THE NATURAL
AND CULTURAL PRESERVE.
AS FOUND IN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE SECTION
FIFTY NINETEEN POINT SEVEN ONE
AND POINT.
SEVEN FOUR UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS THE H. M. V.
R. DIVISION HAS BEEN TRYING TO
PUT AWAY TO THE RECREATION ON TO
LAND NOT APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
USE.
RESEARCH NUMEROUS STUDIES AN
ANALYSIS OF THE O. H. M. V. OURS
DIVISIONS OWN DATA.
DETAIL TEST THOSE RARE AND
IRREPLACEABLE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND SHOW THAT THEY'RE
DISTRIBUTED LAYER UPON LAYER
THROUGHOUT ALMOST THE ENTIRE
EXPANSION AREA.
THE RESOURCES INCLUDE THREATENED
ENDANGERED AND SPECIAL STATUS
SPECIES SENSITIVE HABITATS AND
VEGETATION COMMUNITIES RARE
PLANTS AND A CRITICAL LINKAGE
WILDLIFE CARTER.
AS WITH CLIMATE CHANGE THE
SCIENCE HERE IS CLEAR TESLA HAS
ABUNDANT SENSITIVE RESOURCES AND
MUST BE PROTECTED IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE BOTH TO
PRESERVE THESE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND TO ALLOW -- HD RECREATION AT
TESLA.
TESLA CANNOT BE MOVED AND IT
CANNOT BE REPLACED -- WHICH THE
RECREATION CAN BE LOCATED
ELSEWHERE ON LAND APPROPRIATE
FOR THAT ACTIVITY.
A PREVIOUS BILL SB TWO FORTY
NINE DOES NOT ADDRESS TESLA IN
ANY WAY.
IT BUT IF SB TWO FORTY NINE AND
A PRIOR LAW HAD BEEN FOLLOWED
NEARLY ALL OF TESLA WOULD BE
DESIGNATED AS A LEGALLY DEFINED
SENSITIVE AREA AND PRESERVE
WITHOUT OHB USE.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY SB
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN ADDRESSES A
LOCAL ISSUE WITH UNIQUE HISTORY
INSTEAD OF FACTS.
IT DOES NOT AFFECT THE CARNEGIE
SB ARE A IT DOES NOT ESTABLISH A
PRECEDENT.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESOLVE FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND COUNTING
CONTROVERSY IN A WAY THAT IS
WISE AND FAIR.
IT ALLOWS STATE PARKS TO
CONSIDER THE BROADER PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THE USE OF TESLA.
IT ALLOWS FOR THE SALE OF TESTS
THE FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES
AND RETURNS PROCEEDS TO THE HMV
OUR DIVISION.
FINALLY SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
ALIGNS WITH OUR STATE'S NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCIES MISSION TO
RESTORE PROTECT AND MANAGE THE
STATE'S NATURAL HISTORICAL AND
CULTURAL RESOURCES FOR CURRENT
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR YES VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT.
MORNING -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DUCK HOUSTON
REPRESENTING EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT WE TOO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY FORTY SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVID TâM.
ON THE BEHALF OF THE
SUSTAINABILITY PARKS RECYCLING
AND WILDLIFE LEGAL DEFENSE.
FAYE YOUNGER FROM LIVERMORE
FRIENDS OF LIVERMORE'S SO I'M
REPRESENT EIGHTEEN AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
I'M DAVID FREEZE CONSERVATION
CHAIR OF THE SAN JOAQUIN AUDUBON
SOCIETY SIGN WORKING ON A
FATHER'S HOPE ON SOCIETY
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
THANK.
HELLO I'M DELIA TAYLOR
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
EAST BAY CHAPTER THAT'S ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES AND
THE CALIFORNIA GRASSLANDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M DAVID FIRST
TIME ELECTED DIRECTOR AND
CURRENTLY CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE LIVERMORE AREA
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT.
WHERE AN INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICT NOT CONNECTED WITH THE
CITY AND OUR SERVICE AREA
INCLUDES THE TESLA PROPERTY?
OUR BORDER DIRECTORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
WHEN WE URGE YOU TO PASS IT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M TAMERA ROYCE --
PRESIDENT OF FRIENDS OF OPEN
SPACE AND VINEYARDS WERE BASED
IN LIVERMORE IN THE TRI VALLEY
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DICTIONARY -- CHAIR OF THE TRI
VALLEY GROUP OF THE SIERRA CLUB
WHICH ENCOMPASSES THE ALAMEDA
TESLA EXPANSION AREA AND SIERRA
CLUB REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
ULTIMA LANDFILL OPEN SPACE
COMMITTEE WHICH HAS MITIGATION
FUNDS TO PURCHASE.
THE ENTIRE.
PRETTY ABOUT BOTH THE SIERRA
CLUB AND THE ALTAMONT OPEN SPACE
COMMITTEE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
I'M JOHN COFFEY HOLD FROM
LIVERMORE HI REPRESENTS TRI
VALLEY TRAIL BLAZERS WHICH IS
NONPROFIT RECREATIONAL
EQUESTRIAN GROUP WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M FRED CAUFIELD.
AND I'VE REPRESENTING THE
LIVERMORE WHOLE HIKERS AND THE
FRIENDS OF THE ARROYO AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT PASSAGE OF THIS
BILL.
I MARYLAND SAGE AND RUSSELL I
WERE A NUMBER OF HATS I AM A
BIOLOGIST AND A RANCHER AND I
REPRESENT SEVERAL LARGE GROUPS
I'M A DIRECTOR ON THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY ALL RESOURCE CONSERVATION
BOARD.
THAT SENT A LETTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT I ALSO -- REPRESENT
TESSLER ROAD RESIDENTS ALLIANCE
OF OVER FORTY FAMILIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND ALSO I REPRESENT
EAST ALAMEDA COUNTY RANCHERS WHO
KNOW AND LOVE THIS LAND AND WISH --
TO PRESERVE IT FOR THE FUTURE SO
I STRONGLY SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX OF SEVEN SIX SEVEN
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER SPENCE
AND I REPRESENT THE SOCIETY OF
AMERICANINDIANS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KATHERINE PRESS TRAVEL
CHAIRPERSON OF THE NORTHERN
VALLEY OKAY ALONI BAIT ME WALK.
OF A TRIBAL CHAIRPERSON ALSO
SUPPORTS AND OUR MEMBERS THE US
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN I
ALSO WHERE THEY HAD OF THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION OF CULTURAL REAP
RESOURCES.
I'M ROLE PEREZ AND NOR IN VALLEY
OKAY -- TRIBE IN HIGH REPEAT
READ SUPPORT A BILL TO HIS WELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARCUS GRAHAM A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
ARCHAEOLOGISTS HERE WITH THE
NORTHERN VALLEY OKAY STRIVE WHEN
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON SENATE BILL.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS LUCAS FOR EXAM
HAVE THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SEVEN SIX
SEVEN THINK CENTER GLAZER AND
SOMEONE WERE BACKED BY OUR QUE
HAN FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
ONE DOLLAR GOES ON THE NINETIES
MANAGER FOR SAY ABOUT DOUBLE ON
BEHALF OF OUR TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE YOUR G. TOO STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN THANK
YOU ALL.
ARTHUR ALL LIVERMORE HERITAGE
YIELD WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU -- PHILIP GORDON
HAYWARD -- REPRESENTING THE US
CITIZENS -- TO SAY THE REFUGE
FOR THE DON EDWARDS DISCOVERY
NATIONAL WILDLIFE REFUGE.
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL STRONGLY.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M PAT GORDON FROM HAYWARD
OF REPRESENTING ALONI AUDUBON
SOCIETY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS --
OF SOUTHERN AND EASTERN ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
AND WE STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I MEAN ESCALANTE
I'M FROM CASTRO VALLEY AND TODAY
I'M REPRESENTING AMOUNT JOBLO
AUDUBON SOCIETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M JUDY WILL THINK
FROM CASTRO VALLEY CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT THE HUDDLE.
ENVIRONMENT NOW GROUP AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
I'M JOE LOUIS I'M ALSO FROM THE
CASTRO VALLEY HUDDLE GROUP AND
INCIDENTALLY I'VE BEEN A
VOLUNTEER AND OUR LOCAL WILDLIFE
CENTER IN HAYWARD.
THROUGH THE HAIR RECREATION
DEPARTMENT FOR TEN YEARS WHERE
WE HAVE THE DISTINCT.
OF OPPORTUNITY TO CARE FOR
INJURED WHILE I'VE IN ANIMALS
AND WE DO THE BEST WE CAN BUT IF
WE CAN KEEP ANIMALS INTO SAFE
PROTECTED AREA.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE BEST THING SO
I THINK THIS IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE A
CRITICAL PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
YOU'RE VOTING FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CELESTE CAM INDEED
WITH FRIENDS OF TESLA PARK AND
WE ASK FOR YOU SUPPORT AT THIS
BILL TO PRESERVE THIS UNIQUE
IRREPLACEABLE LAND WHICH IS
REALLY A BENEFIT TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU I
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TERRY MCHALE WITH
THEIR AND READ AND SO SEATS.
REPRESENTING A CONSORTIUM OF OUR
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION
THIS.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL LAST YEAR.
AND WE OPPOSE IT THIS YEAR THE
MAJOR DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
IS THAT THE PURCHASE PRICE LAST
YEAR WAS THE WAS THE CEILING IN
THIS YEAR IT'S THE FLOOR.
BUT IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH AND WE
WOULD SUGGEST IF THIS GOES TO IF
IT GOES TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS.
THAT IF THIS LAND IS SOLD IT
SOLD AT MARKET VALUE.
THIS PROPERTY WAS SET ASIDE FOR
A SPECIFIC PURPOSE.
HE WAS SET ASIDE BY EARMARKED
FUNDS AND WAS SATISFIED BY
PEOPLE WHO PAID FOR THROUGH THE
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITY AND THE
RED AND GREEN STICKER FEE.
THAT MONEY IS REAL IT BELONGS TO
THEM AND BE WRONG TO STEAL THEIR
LAND AND THEN TAKE THEIR MONEY.
TO NUMBER.
TWO WE SPENT A YEAR.
WORKING ON OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION TO MAKE THE OF THE
PROGRAM PERMANENT.
THE BILL WAS SB.
TWO FORTY NINE IT WAS SUGGESTED
IN EARLIER TESTIMONY THAT HAD SB
TWO FORTY NINE BEEN IN PLACE.
THAT TESLA WOULD HAVE BEEN
PRESERVED AS IT EXISTS RIGHT NOW.
LET ME BE CLEAR I SAT IN ON
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
MEETINGS ON SB.
TWO FORTY NINE TESLA
REPRESENTATIVES CAME TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE DISCUSSION AND
THEN LEFT AND REFUSED TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND THE REASON THEY REFUSE TO
PARTICIPATE IS BECAUSE WE WOULD
NOT.
WE WOULD NOT DO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
SO AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THEY
WITHDREW.
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THEY
DID NOT EVEN SUPPORT THE BILL
WHEN IT WAS CONCLUDED.
NUMBER THREE THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLUS STATE
PARKS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF THEM HAVE EXTRAORDINARY
VALUE -- HD SUPPORTS THE
CATHEDRAL PARKS WE SUPPORT THE
PARKS WHERE YOU CAN WALK WE
SUPPORT THE PARKS.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT FAMILIES GO
TO PICNIC OR PEOPLE GOING TO
HIKE ONLY EIGHT OF THEM. EIGHT
OF THEM ARE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION AREAS.
THEY PRODUCE A BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A IT'S A PROGRAM THAT.
THE THE DIRECTOR OF CAL PARKS
CALLED IN TESTIMONY.
A NATIONAL MODEL.
US SO THE IDEA YOU KNOW WHEN I
BILL SHOW THE PICTURES ALSO THE
DAMAGED HILLSIDES.
IN THOSE SAY THIS IS AN EXAMPLE.
OF THE CORRUPTING INFLUENCE OF
HV.
WELL I WOULD SAY THERE'S ONLY
EIGHT OF AND WHEN I GO TO AN OHP
PARK AND I SEE THOSE HILLSIDES
WITH PATHWAYS I SEE A SAFER WAY
TO RECREATION.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT EIGHTH SB TWO FORTY NINE
WHEN YOU SEE THAT CORRUPTED HILL
SIDE.
WE HAVE MADE AN AGREEMENT.
THAT IT WILL BE RESTORED
PERIODICALLY TO PRISTINE
ACTIVITY AND WE MOVED TO A
DIFFERENT AREA WITHIN THE PARK --
HV RECREATION AS A NATIONAL
MODEL BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE
SCIENTISTS WORKING -- FOR H. B.
RECREATION THAN ANY OTHER PART
OF THE PARKS.
THAT WE SPEND MORE TIME ON
CULTURAL AND NATURAL RESOURCES
THAN ANY OTHER PART OF THE
PARK'S.
WHEN THE INDIVIDUALS UP HERE SAY
THAT THEY'RE CONCERNED?
THAT -- H. B. WILL DESTROY THE
AREA I WOULD SUGGEST ALSO THAT
THERE ARE AREAS IN ALMOST EVERY
OHB PARKING WHICH CULTURAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE SET ASIDE
AND PRESERVED.
NUMBER FOUR IMAGINE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A WAY TO BE.
IMAGINE THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION.
THEN I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE ARE
ESTABLISHING A VERY DIFFICULT
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS. FOR
DECADES WHEN LOCAL PROPERTY IS
GOING TO BE USED BY THE STATE
THERE ARE EXTENSIVE HEARINGS AND
THE LOCALS ARE INVITED TO BE A
PART OF IT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
NOW WHAT THIS BILL SAYS IS OKAY
THERE IS AN AGREEMENT THE MONEY
IS SET ASIDE FOR ABOUT TO DO IT
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO THROW
THAT PROCESS OUT.
AND MAKE IT A MULLIGAN.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO BACK AND REDO
THE HEARINGS AGAIN.
WELL.
IF YOU LIVE IN A BEACH AREA THEN
YOU WAKE UP AND YOU SAY I DON'T
WANT MY BEACH BEING TOUCH
BECAUSE PEOPLE SHOW UP AND RUN
ON THE BEACH ARE GONNA CREATE.
DUST PARTICULATES ARE TOO MUCH
NOISE OR TOO MUCH TRAFFIC WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
AND IF YOU GO TO AN AREA WHERE
IT'S MOUNTAIN BIKING.
AND PEOPLE ARE UPSET BECAUSE THE
RIGHTS OF THE MOUNTAIN BIKE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE HORSES IN
THESE AREAS AND WHAT WE SET
ASIDE THE HORSES WE GO BACK AND
LOCAL SAY MY GOD HORSES DO WITH
HORSES DO.
AND WE DON'T WANT THAT BEING
DONE WHAT THIS WOULD DO WOULD BE
TO SET UP A PRECEDENT IN WHICH
ALL.
OF THE LANDS BEING SET ASIDE BY
NATURAL RESOURCES BY RESOURCES
OR BY PARKS WOULD BE OPEN TO THE
DISCUSSION.
NUMBER.
FIVE THIS BILL ONLY SAYS.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THE PROCESS
OF PROCESSES BEEN TRIED AND TRUE
AND EFFECTIVE IN WORKABLE WAS
SOMEHOW FAULTED.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE IT WAS OR IF
IT SAYS THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
IN THE LOCALS WHO SIGNED OFF.
ON TESLA.
MANY OF THEM WHO MADE AGREEMENTS
AS TESLA WAS SATISFIED.
NOW SAY THAT IT'S UNFAIR.
THEN THE LAND GETS SOLD.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ON RECORD AND
I'D LIKE THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
ON RECORD TO STATE OF THE COURTS.
IF PER CHANCE THIS BILL PASSES
AND SIGNED IN TAKES PLACE.
AFTER THE HEARING TAKES PLACE
AND IT TURNS OUT.
THAT PARKS DID EVERYTHING RIGHT.
THAT WE STOP THE NONSENSE AND WE
EXPEDITE MAKING THIS -- HV
PROPERTY.
A NUMBER NINE IT'S JUST ON A
PERSONAL NOTE.
THIS IS A VERY PASSIONATE ISSUE --
ERIN RITA SO SEATS WERE LUCKY TO
REPRESENT A LOT OF EXCELLENT
CLIENTS.
THE WAY TO BE IS ALWAYS SORT OF
THE RED HEADED STEP CHILD OF
PARKS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO COME IN AND IT
GETS VERY PASSIONATE ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I WANT TO SAY I
ALWAYS DISLIKED BEING ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF SENATOR GLAZER.
I THINK HE'S AN INCREDIBLY
CONSCIENTIOUS LEGISLATOR.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO WORKS HARDER FOR HIS
CONSTITUENTS.
AND I KNOW THE BILL WAS UP LAST
YEAR AND HE WILL COME BACK NEXT
YEAR AND COME BACK FOR EVER ON
THIS BILL.
HOWEVER HAVING SAID THAT I THINK
IT IS WRONG CITED I THINK IT
GOES IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
AND I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
REJECTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AMY
GRANITE AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
OFF ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION -- BUT I HAVE TO
CONFESS THAT I'M JUST AN AVERAGE
OFF ROADER I'M NOT A LOBBYIST
AND I DON'T SPEAK PROFESSIONALLY
IN FRONT OF HEARINGS.
BUT WHAT I DO WANT TO SAY IS
THAT AS AN AVERAGE OFF ROADER
AVERAGE OPERATORS DESERVE A
VOICE TO AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN GRANTED AT
ALL IN THIS PROCESS AND IT'S
VERY VERY FRUSTRATING -- INSTEAD
WE'VE BEEN PAINTED AS
IRRESPONSIBLE WE'VE BEEN PAINTED
WITH.
MANY MANY ADJECTIVES THAT NOBODY
WOULD LIKE TO BEAR.
SOMETIMES IT'S DIFFICULT TO
SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER BUT IN THIS
CASE WE FIND THAT WE HAVE.
TO THE ILL CONCEIVED TRAVESTY
THAT IS SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN IS
GONE ON TOO LONG FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO BE POLITE.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS BILL
CHEATS THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA AS
WEALTHY AND POLITICALLY
CONNECTED INDIVIDUALS USE
POLITICIANS AND THE POLITICAL
SYSTEM TO GET THEIR WAY.
NOW THE BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED TO
CHEAT OFF ROADERS OUT OF THE
LAND THEY PAID FOR OUT OF THE
WHICH WE TRUST FUND.
AND CHEAP THE WHICH WE TRUST
FUND OUT OF ANY MEANING FULL
REIMBURSEMENT.
AS OFF ROADERS WE GET USED TO
THE NAME CALLING WE GET USED TO
THE IDEOLOGY BASED ON HATE FOR
WHAT WE DO.
THIS BILL ALSO CHEATS STATE
PARKS AT OF ALL THE TIME AND ALL
THE MONEY THEY SPENT OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS PUTTING INTO
IMPROVEMENTS INTO THE ALAMEDA
TESSLER EXPANSION AREA. FOR WHAT
GOAL.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
PRIVATIZE A STATE PARK? TO
CREATE AN EXCLUSIVE PLAYGROUND
CLOSE TO ANYONE THAT OTHERS
WOULD DEEM UNWORTHY.
IT SETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
THAT WOULD ALLOW ANY SEMBLANCE
OF ACCUSATION TO BE USED AS AN
EXCUSE. TO FORCE THE SALE OF A
STATE PARK AND KEEP OUT QUOTE
UNQUOTE UNDESIRABLE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC.
RESPECTFULLY THIS BILL WOULD
DEPRIVE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS OF ACCESS SHORT
CHANGES THE STATE OUT OF MONEY
SPENT PER STATE LAW WITH GOOD
INTENT AND WHAT COULD.
CAUSE HARM TO THE AREA ITSELF
COUNTER TO WHAT IS PREVIOUSLY
BEEN TESTIFIED BECAUSE HE ALWAYS
CHEN BR DIVISION THE STATE PARK
ACTUALLY HAS THE HIGHEST
MANDATED -- CAM STRINGENT
ECONOMIC REGULATIONS OF ANYONE
ANY COUNTY PARK IN THE STATE
PARK ANY OF AND CERTAINLY ANY
PRIVATE PROPERTY -- THEY SPEND
MORE MONEY ON ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS AND ANY OTHER ENTITY
OF STATE PARKS -- THE SUPPORTERS
OF THE ONLY ONES TO GAME THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO TOLD ME.
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE LIKE YOU IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND THAT ACTUALLY
WAS SAID TO BE IN ONE OF THESE
MEETINGS I UNDERSTAND THE
MEETINGS GET HEATED.
BUT THAT TYPE OF APPROACH THAT
STATEMENT SHOULD NEVER BE SAID
TO ANYBODY -- AT THE TIME I HAD
MY SERVICE DOG WITH ME AND ASKED
YOU KNOW WAS IT AN ISSUE THAT I
WAS A GRANDMOTHER WERE DOG OWNER
WHICH ONE AND OF COURSE THEY
DIDN'T LIKE IT AND WALKED AWAY --
WE CANNOT ALLOW ELITISM TO WIN
AND WE CANNOT ALLOW LEADERS AND
TO TAKE AWAY STATE PARKS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM
THE BAY AREA WHAT YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY GO TO CARNEGIE.
LOT OF PEOPLE FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY GO TO CARNEGIE.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE A LOT OF
PEOPLE FROM SACRAMENTO GO TO
CARNEGIE [inaudible]
POLICIES.
NICE RING -- TO I'M OLD ENOUGH
THAT I REMEMBER WHERE THAT CAME
FROM -- BUT ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
MANY OF THEM ARE HARD WORKING
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN COME TO A
HEARING LIKE THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE YOUNG THEY HAVE FAMILIES
THEY WORK FOR A LIVING AND THEY
CAN'T TAKE OFF.
EVERY TIME THIS BILL IS BEING
HEARD SO THEREFORE I HAVE TO TRY
AND EXPRESS THEIR FRUSTRATION
THAT THEY ARE NOT BEING HEARD --
AGAIN.
WE ASK THAT YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL NOT TO ALLOW THIS PRESIDENT
TO BE SET.
IN TO REALLY STAND UP FOR THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA -- BECAUSE WE
NEED [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS CAN ONLY -- AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE MODESTO RIDGE
RUNNERS THE MERCED RUNABOUTS THE
EAST BAY HIGH TAILORS AND
CORVETTE.
I HEARD TWO COMMENTS TODAY ABOUT
THE LAND BEING APPROPRIATE FOR
OFF ROAD USE.
SENATOR GLAZER ANOTHER HEARINGS
I'VE HEARD HIM SAY THERE'S NO.
CHANCE THEY'RE GOING I'M SORRY
BUT I WITH ADDITIONAL I SPEAKERS
WE WE ONLY HAVE TIME FOR YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON ON THE BILL OKAY.
I REPRESENT THE OFF ROADERS I
MENTIONED AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE.
OUR THIRTY ONE HUNDRED ACRES
PLUS SO THAT WE CAN RECREATION.
I'M CHARLES HERRINGTON I'M
REPRESENTING THE REDNECK
ROOSTERS AND A TABLEAU WHEELERS.
WE'RE PART OF THE ECOLOGY TO AND
I WOULD LIKE SOME PLACE THAT I
CAN GO AFTER WORK AND RELAX TOO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST JUST TO CLARIFY
PLEASE JUST STATE NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BALLOT.
MY JOSH APPEAR ON MY
AFFILIATIONS I'M JUST A DAD IN
OFF ROADER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH SHAPIRO I
AM A MOTHER OF AN OFF ROAD OR
THE WIFE OF AN OFF ROADER.
AND I AM AGAINST THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS MAN SHOULD PARA
AND AND THE SISTER I'M YOUNGER
SISTER FLUFF ORDER.
THEM AGAINST THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARK SHAPIRO I'M A
DIRT BIKE ENTHUSIASTS NATURE
LOVER AND I'M AGAINST THIS BILL.
ONE RENTALS -- MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF LAW CAL FOUR WHEEL WE
HAVE OVER EIGHT THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SPENCER GILBERT SURE TRAILS
LANCE BLUE RIBBON COALITION BY A
CAPITAL AND RESIDENT OF THE BAY
AREA.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL WITH OUR
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS.
SHERRI STORAGE AROUND TWENTY
NINE YEAR MEMBER OF CAL FOUR AND
A SPREE TO FOUR FOUR WHEEL DRIVE
CLUB.
I I'M GONNA START OUT BY SAYING
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN I BELIEVE
I'M THE IBM VIOLATES IF YOU CAN
JUST STATE.
YOUR POSITION ON THE BALL I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IT VIOLATES SYKORA POLITICIANS
NEED TO THANK YOU.
COMPLY WITH SINCLAR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING THIS I'M
KEN CLARKE I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA OFF ROAD VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION.
I AM ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
WANDERING WHEELERS JEEP CLUB
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA WERE LOCAL
GROUP.
I'M ALSO A SENIOR CITIZEN WITH
DISABILITIES AND A PERSON A
NATIVE AMERICAN THIS DESCENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FIERCELY THANK YOU.
DIANA MEAD CALIFORNIA OFF ROAD
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION --
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR GLAZER
WITH WHOM I MADE SEVERAL EFFORTS
TO MEET PERSONALLY.
ON THIS TOPIC AND NEVER WAS ABLE
TO GET THAT -- I POSE THIS BILL.
WARNING CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MANNERS DON AMADOR WITH AMY
DISTRICT THIRTY SIX I WAS ON THE
EACH BE COMMISSION IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN --
PURCHASES PROPERTY NOT A SINGLE
ONE OF THESE PEOPLE THAT CAME
BEFORE YOU TODAY OPPOSE THE
PROJECT THEN.
IN FACT ONE OF THE MAIN
PROPONENT TERRIFYING AGREEMENT
TO SUPPORT THE PROJECT IN THE
TERM WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE WE WE WILL ONLY HAVE TIME
FOR EVERYBODY TO SAY THEIR NAME
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BALL.
MY NAME'S AT WILLIS I'M --
CONCESSIONAIRE WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALWAYS FEE PARK
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING DAVE TICKET PRIOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION OFFICER FOR A
MAY DISTRICT THIRTY SIX AS WELL
AS C. E. R. A MEMBER CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE WRITERS ASSOCIATION.
MADAM CHAIR I WOULD APPRECIATE
AT LEAST A MINUTE.
AS WAS AFFORDED TO THE PEOPLE
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SIR IT'S IT'S OUR POLICY THAT WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYONE TO THANK YOU THEIR NAME
THANK YOU REST HERE THANK YOU OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE PARKS
HAS MADE IT VERY CLEAR THEY DO
NOT.
SUPPORT SERVICE BILL SIR THIS IS
TOTALLY.
ACCEPTABLE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE OFF
ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OKAY I BRING IT BACK TO I JUST
SERVANT HAS CONTACTS WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE FROM
BOTH SIDES.
HI AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY AND WE'VE HAD YEAR
FIFTY FOLKS IN SUPPORT FIFTY
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
EVERYONE'S OF EVERYONE'S TIME
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE
BEING HERE TO TO MAKE YOUR
VOICES HEARD ABOUT THIS THE
SUBJECT.
I BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AND I'D
LIKE THE SENATOR HAVE A MOMENT
TO RESPOND TO A COUPLE THE
CONCERNS PRIMARILY THE THE ISSUE
OF ON THE LAND BEING.
RESOLD AT MARKET VALUE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF THAT THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO THE BILL
DOES PROVIDE -- THAT THAT CANNOT
IT CANNOT BE SOLD FOR LESS THAN
THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE --
THAT'S THE REQUIREMENTS -- IN
THE BILL -- AND AND THE OTHER
THING THAT TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THIS BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
SALE OF THE PROPERTY.
I IT JUST SAYS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND RACK IF
THEY CHOOSE OF THEIR CHOOSING
NOW.
DECIDE THAT THAT THAT IT'S NOT
WORTH IT TO CONTINUE TO PURSUE
THIS OFF ROAD VEHICLE PARK.
THIS BILL GIVES AND THE OPTION.
TO WILL HAVE THE THE THE THE
LAND DIESEL FOR PUBLIC USE.
PUBLIC PRESERVATION BUT IT SAYS
IN THE BILL BUT NO LESS THAN THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE OF ALL
THE MONEY.
THAT WAS PAID FOR THE LAND
ORIGINALLY THAT WOULD GET IT ALL
BACK.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WITH THE BILL.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION IS THERE
A SECOND.
RIGHT I'LL GO AHEAD AND SECOND
THE MOTION I'M.
RIGHT SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BURKE [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO MEDINA NOT VOTING
MEDINA NOT LOADING [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI SMITH SMITH HI.
I'D SAY THAT BILL NEEDS ONE MORE
WILL GO AHEAD AND LEAVE THE I
NEED TO PUT THAT ON CALL AND
WAIT FOR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WITNESSES
WHO CAME UP HERE TO TESTIFY.
OKAY MOVING I TO FILE ITEM --
FOR SENATOR CHIANG
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
A GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL.
THREE FORTY EIGHT SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY IT WOULD CALL ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT THE USE OF ART
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE FIVE
BETTER SERVICE AND DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES.
ACROSS AMERICA STATES LIKE
INDIANA NEW YORK AND
MASSACHUSETTS HAVE TAKEN STEPS
TO STUDY THE ISSUE OF A AYE ITS
IMPLICATIONS AND POSSIBLE
REGULATIONS.
I BELIEVE THAT PART OF OUR JOB
AS LEGISLATORS IS TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT ACCESSIBLE AND
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
PART OF MAKING GOVERNMENT
ACCESSIBLE IS USING NEW AND
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDE A
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE FOR THOSE
WHO INTERACT WITH DIFFERENT
PARTS OF OUR STATE GOVERNMENT.
WE NEED TO ACT NOW TO BRING THAT
TECHNOLOGICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
VARIOUS AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
RECENT AMENDMENTS HELP LINE THIS
BILL WITH OTHER LEGISLATION ON A
AYE TO ENSURE THEY COMPLEMENT
EACH OTHER.
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
REPORT THIS YEAR'S SOUNDED THE
ALARM THAT THE STATE IS NOT
PROPERLY FOCUSED ON A AYE AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WAS THE
FOUNDATION FOR THIS BILL.
A I WAS COMING WHETHER WE LIKE
IT OR NOT AND WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED TO ACCEPT AND USE THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO THE BEST OF ITS
POTENTIAL AS WELL AS MEDICAID
FOR RISKS.
THIS BILL CODIFIES THAT STATE
LEADERS NEED TO FOCUS ON THIS
ISSUE IN A HOLISTIC WAY.
THIS BILL HAS ZERO NO VOTES AND
WAS ON CONSENT AND PRIVACY
COMMITTEE AND WITH ME HERE TODAY
IS TO LISTEN TO GONZALEZ OF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION TO
SHARE THEIR PERSPECTIVE WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HE SAID THAT GONZALEZ
AND I'M A RESEARCH ANALYST WITH
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE FORTY EIGHT THE COMMISSION
IS AN INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
RECOMMENDING WAYS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
STATE GOVERNMENT.
LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION BEGAN A
STUDY TO UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
STATE IS PREPARING FOR THE USE
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT A I CAN
PROVIDE TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AFTER AN ELEVENTH MONTH STUDY
THE COMMISSION RELEASED ITS
REPORT.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE A
ROADMAP FOR CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH OUR STUDY THE COMMISSION
AND IDENTIFIED MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO USE A AYE.
LET ME CITE JUST TWO EXAMPLES A
I SYSTEMS ALLOWED SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN TACOMA
WASHINGTON TO IDENTIFY APRS
STUDENTS AND INTERVENE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT.
RAISING GRADUATION RATES.
AND MICHIGAN USES A AYE TO
PREDICT THE LIKELIHOOD OF DRUG
RELATED DEATHS AND REVEAL OTHER
INSIGHTS INTO THE STATE'S --
OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND WHILE
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT HAS
MADE STRIDES TO IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES
EMPLOYING MODERN TECHNOLOGY.
IT IS UNDER PREPARED TO RESPOND
AND ADAPT TO THE RAPID CHANGES
BROUGHT BY THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND IT
TECHNOLOGICAL POWER HOUSE.
BUT THE COMMISSION FOUND THAT A
STRATEGIC PLANNING VOID EXISTS
IN STATE GOVERNMENT AROUND
SEIZING OPPORTUNITIES OF A AYE
AND MINIMIZING ITS REST.
OUR REPORT ISSUE TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP FILL
THIS VOID AND PROVIDE THE VISION
OF COORDINATION AND SYSTEM
SUSTAINED UNIFIED EFFORT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO GOVERN FOR THE
FUTURE.
AMONG ITS RECOMMENDATIONS THE
COMMISSION CALLED FOR THE
CREATION OF STATE LEAD TO
STRATEGIC PLANS FOR THE USE OF A
AYE TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES AND MINIMIZE
THE IMPACT ON THE STATE'S WORK
FORCE AND JOB CLASSIFICATIONS.
THE COMMISSION ALSO CARD CALLED
FOR THE GOVERNOR TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL ADVISER ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO DEVELOP A
STRAIGHT WHITE STATEWIDE
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT INCORPORATES
A AYE WHEN IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND RECOMMENDED ENCOURAGING
CERTAIN INDEPENDENT OFFICES TO
DESIGNATE ACHIEVE A AYE OFFICER.
SB THREE FORTY EIGHT WOULD
ADVANCE THE GOALS OF THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND
HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY FOCUS ON THE
STRATEGIC DEVELOPMENT AND USE OF
A AYE TECHNOLOGY FOR THE BENEFIT
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
SEE NINE OUT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I I HAVE A QUESTION IS I'VE
SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR I AM SO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE AS A STATE.
I LOOKED STRATEGICALLY AT A AYE
AT AUTOMATION.
AND UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS
OF TECHNOLOGY FOR THE FUTURE OF
GOVERNMENT AND FOR THE FUTURE OF
WORK.
MY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT IT.
IT'S SEEMS DUPLICATIVE OF AB
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EITHER.
I HAVE JUST BEEN IMPLEMENTED FOR
A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED IN THE SESSION SO.
I THE GOVERNOR AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE MAYES AS MAY SIGN
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND ELEVEN
NINETEEN WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
FUTURE OF WORK COMMISSION.
I AM NOT IS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON A NUMBER OF THINGS INCLUDING
AUTOMATION OF JOBS ANDEXPANDED
A AYE CAPABILITIES.
I AB NINE SEVENTY SIX CHAO WHICH
YOUR YOUR BELL REFERENCES
CREATES AN A I COMMISSION.
AB FIVE NINETY FOUR AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS WHICH IS
REQUIRING THE DIRECTOR OF C. D.
T. TO APPOINT A CHIEF A AYE
OFFICER.
ENVELOP STRATEGIC PLANS AT
CENTER AT AND I GUESS HELP ME
UNDERSTAND HOW.
WHAT IS IN THIS BILL?
IS.
INCREMENTAL TO ALL THAT OTHER.
EITHER CURRENT OR OR PROPOSED
LEGISLATION AND I THINK FOR ME
YOU KNOW THAT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL WE AREN'T A POLICY
COMMITTEE IN THE SAME WAY THAT
OTHER POLICY COMMITTEES IN A
LOOK AT THAT.
IDEA WE'RE NOT JUST LOOKING AT
GOOD IDEAS THE EXPRESS PURPOSE
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
IS TO INCREASE IN EFFICIENCY AND
THE OPERATIONS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT IS WHEN I LOOK AT ALL
THOSE BELLS AND ALL THOSE LAWS
I'M LIKE WHY IN THE WORLD WE
NEED. FIVE NEW LAWS TO DO THE
SAME THING -- SO WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND HOW
YOU FEEL THAT THIS IS A UNIQUE
AND DIFFERENTIATED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION -- WHEN COMPARED TO
THAT THAT LANDSCAPE?
RIGHT SO.
I KNOW YOU AND I HAVE.
A DISCUSS A LITTLE BIT OF ABOUT
THIS LAST NIGHT BUT WE HAVE
WORKED WITH -- CHARLES COMMITTEE
TO PUT IN AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOES NOT -- OVERLAP
OR IT'S IT'S NOT DUPLICATIVE OF
OTHER BILLS SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU
MENTIONED THAT -- HE'S CREATING
AN A I COMMISSION FROM MY BILL
DOES NOT CREATE NAY I'M IN A I'M
MISSION IT JUST TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION WHAT THEIR
FINDINGS ARE.
AND AS A SECTION THREE STATES --
THIS SECTION TWO OF THIS ACTUAL
BECOME OPERATIVE ONLY IF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SOME SIX
WHICH IS THE CHILD BILL.
OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY REGULAR SESSION IS AN
ACTIVE AND BECOMES OPERATIVE IN
WHICH SECTION IN WHICH CASE
SECTION ONE OF THIS ACTUAL NOT
BECOME.
OPERATIVE SO WE PUT MEASURES
THAT WE PUT AMENDMENTS IN PLACE
SO THAT DOESN'T IT IT -- TO IT
CLARIFIES THAT IT'S NOT
DUPLICATIVE.
AND THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT
PORTIONS OF THE THE BILL OF
DIFFERENT BILLS ARE ALL PORTIONS
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
AND SO I FEEL LIKE IT'S MORE ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT BILLS ARE.
COMPLEMENTARY TO EACH OTHER.
AND I ALSO TALKED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECH.
REGARDING THIS BILL AND I SAID
HEY WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT WHICH AGENCIES -- SHOULD
BE -- A TACKLE WITH THOSE TO BE
A A STRATEGIC PLAN AND THEY SAID
OURS.
AND SO THEY THEY ARE FULLY ON
BOARD WITH -- OF MY PLAN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
STEPS OUT THE SALAS BILL THAT IS
CREATING A DIRECTOR WITH IN
SORRY THE CHIEF A AYE OFFICER
WITH AND THE CD T..
WHO WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR A AYE?
IT WOULD BE THE DIRECTOR OF
TECHNOLOGY SHALL DEVISE A
STRATEGIC.
PLAN DESIGNED TO EIGHT
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES SO NOT
A SPECIFIC.
A I SO IT.
IT IT'S NOT OF DEPENDENT UPON
THE PASSAGE OF OF HIS BILL OKAY.
RIGHT THE THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS
AS I SAID I'D.
CERTAINLY AND SUPER SUPPORTIVE
OF THE INTENT TO THE BALLOT
PRESHOW YOUR FOCUS ON THE
SUBJECT THINK IT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT.
MY REASON FOR BEING A NO TODAY
IS SIMPLY I LIKE IS THAT I THINK
IT CREATES REDUNDANT
REQUIREMENTS AND REDUNDANT COSTS
AND IN THE CONTEXT OF CHAIRING A
COMMITTEE WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT MORE EFFICIENT.
I CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD AROUND THAT
I AM I CAN ALSO HAVE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION COMMENT ON ON
OKAY I WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU --
THE DIFFERENT BILLS THAT YOU
HAVE REFERENCE ARE ALL SUPPORTED
BY THE COMMISSION THEY COME FROM --
DIFFERENT RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THE COMMISSION IS MADE -- AND SO
WE SEE THEM AS COMPLEMENTARY TO
EACH OTHER.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
UP.
I WANTED TO IT I YOU COULD YOU
CLARIFY I THINK WITH RESPECT TO
THE DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN THE
THE OTHER BILLS.
BUT I I JUST I WANTED.
TO AT LEAST COM AT THAT LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION.
IN MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN.
UP ABOUT EFFICIENCIES AND
STREAMLINING AND FIGURING OUT
WAYS TO DO THIS KIND OF STUFF
BETTER SO IT SEEMS TO ME IT FITS.
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANTLY.
TO THE TASK OF OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND SO YOU DID SAY THAT IN THE
COMMISSION'S JUDGMENT THESE.
OTHER BILLS ARE COMPLIMENTARY
AND ARE NOT.
DUPLICATIVE AND ARE IN YOUR VIEW.
NECESSARY FOR THE APPROPRIATE.
APPROACH TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS MADE IT
MY UNDERSTAND IT CORRECTLY
[inaudible]
AND BECAUSE WE JUST SEE -- THE
IMPLICATIONS THAT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE CAN HAVE ON THE
STATE AND CALIFORNIANS WE WE
FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT THESE BILLS
YEAH RIGHT.
THANK YOU UP WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT I WITH THAT AS A
CRITIC CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS.
NO PETRIE-NORRIS NOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HI BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA.
MEDINA NOW QUIRK SILVA.
KIRK SILVA AYE SMITH.
SMITH HI.
OKAY GREAT THAT BILLS THROUGH.
AND I WILL MOVE ON TO MISTER
BRADFORD.
I'VE FILE ITEM. SEVEN A C. R..
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU WELL I'LL BE
BRIEF -- S. C. R. THIRTY ONE
SIMPLY -- THE TEMP TO HONOR ALL
WILLIE L. BROWN A FORMER MAYOR
OF SAN FRANCISCO -- FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE SHALL SERVE
FIFTEEN YEARS AND THIS CURRENT.
TERM LIMIT ENVIRONMENT NO ONE
WILL EVER EXCEEDED RECORD WE
KNOW IT'S CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- HE'S
CONSIDERED ONE THE LEADING
POLITICIANS OF TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY NEED TO SIMPLY.
ATTEMPTS TO NAME ON THE PUBLIC
STREET AT NINE FELT FOURTEEN
NINE FIFTEEN CAPITAL MALL TO THE
WILLIE BROWN PLAZA MALL AND I
REQUEST FOR A VOTE.
WE ALL REALLY WANT TO MOVE THIS
BATTLE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSH PANAY -- WANT TO
GIVE MY FULL SUPPORT FOR THIS AS
WELL AND THANK MISTER BRADFORD
FOR DOING THIS -- IT'S A GREAT
HONOR. TO BE A PART OF THIS AND
IT WAS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
COMPLETELY IN THE SENATE TO I
THINK WAS THIRTY SEVEN VOTES
THAT FORD IN THE SENATE NO NO
VOTES SAYS SO WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE BOTH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
HI CELINA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
THEM AND DOUBLE ACP AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT SECRETARY LEE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI BURKE.
LACKING LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA
HI KIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH SMITH HI.
GREAT AT PHYLLIS THREE THINK
ABOUT YOUR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND DIVE MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SECOND JOB OKAY GREAT I
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE CONSENT IS SB.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT THE MOTION TO PASS ARE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON BURKE.
LACKEY LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA
AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH SMITH HI.
ALRIGHT WE ARE JUST WAITING ON
AUTHORS.
BOB WAS AND NOW I DON'T KNOW.
THE POINT REALLY
[inaudible]
YEAH -- OUR RESEARCH
YEAH [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
UHHUH [inaudible]
I DON'T
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND DAD MOVED TO
SENATOR PAUL IS FILE ITEM ONE SB.
SIX MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB -- SIX
THIS IS A BILL THAT CRISIS
SIMPLY -- A CENTRALIZED DATABASE
OF STATE -- AND LOCALLY OWNED
SURPLUS AND VACANT LAND AND
PROPERTIES IDENTIFIED. FOR
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION OR
CONSTRUCTION SO WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE A CENTRALIZED. ONE STOP
SHOP DATABASE -- WE HAVE NO
SILVER BULLET ON THE HOUSING
CRISIS BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO DO
THINGS THAT FACILITATE -- OF THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ONE OF THE SIMPLE THINGS
WE CAN DO IS.
TO USE WHATEVER TECHNOLOGY WE
HAVE TO CREATE A ONE STOP SHOP
CENTRALIZED DATABASE THAT WOULD.
PROVIDE ANYBODY INTERESTED IN
BUILDING HOUSING PRIVATE SECTOR
NON PROFITS -- OTHER GROUPS --
TO HAVE A PLACE THEY CAN GO.
TO START THE PROCESS OF GETTING --
LAND FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
LANCASTER BERRIER TO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SB SIX
PROPOSES -- TO TAKE INFORMATION
IT'S KIND OF ALREADY THERE.
YOU'LL SEE IT THAT WAY.
IT'S ALREADY THERE THIS
INFORMATION IS THERE BUT IT'S
NOT ACCUMULATE IN A WILL AND ONE
LOCATION.
SO WE HAVE WITNESSES SUPPORTING
THIS BILL IT'S A SIMPLE BILL
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO A PARK AND
SALAS AND GIVE YOU THEY'LL GIVE
YOU A PERSPECTIVE AND PEDRO
GOBBLED.
PERSPECTIVE ON FROM THE INDUSTRY
AND LAND TRUST -- SIDE OF THINGS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL GUNS ALL
THIS HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
IRVINE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST WE
ARE ONE OF TWENTY FIVE WHEN
TRUST THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT
PROVIDES -- PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- TO THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES -- THE WAY ENTRUST
MODELS EAGER TO GROW IN THE
STATE AND WE'VE SEEN MANY
BARRIERS AND FROM WHEN IT COMES
TO TRYING TO DEVELOP THESE THESE
PROPERTIES -- THIS BILL WILL DO
A GREAT JOB OF BEING ABLE
CENTRALIZE ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION GIVE US SOME
DIRECTION.
AND ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO
OVERCOME ALL THOSE BARRIERS IT'S
REALLY A VERY SIMPLE BILL BUT
HAS WILL HAVE A GREAT IMPACT AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR PETRIE-NORRIS
MY NAME IS PATRICK OF ALMOST THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION CELEBRATING OUR
FORTIETH YEAR THIS YEAR.
AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX BECAUSE WE SAY IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THERE THREE CRITICAL
COMPONENTS MONEY LAND AND
POLITICAL WILL ON THIS HELPS TO
ADDRESS THE LAND COMPONENT OF IT --
ASSN THE REBELS -- ALLUDED TO
JURISDICTIONS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO IDENTIFY SITES THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENTS.
BUT THIS INFORMATION IS NOT THIS
IN ANY CENTRALIZED DATABASE AND
SB SIX WILL FOR THE FIRST TIME.
BRING THAT AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL -- IN FACT THE ASSOCIATION
OF BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS IN THE
BAY AREA ALREADY DID A SIMILAR
EFFORT -- AND IT WAS INCREDIBLY
ILLUMINATING TO SEE WHAT SITES
JURISDICTIONS HAD ALREADY
IDENTIFIED FOR HOUSING.
AND WHETHER THEY COULDBE PUT TO
IMMEDIATE USE AND WE THINK
HAVING THIS TOOL WILL HELP SHAVE
OFF SOME VALUABLE TIME OFF THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS TO HELP GET
PEOPLE HOUSED.
FASTER -- AFFORDABLY HOUSE
FASTER IN OUR STATE AND SO ON
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS A JULIE SNYDER WITH
EQUITY ADVOCATES REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA -- HOUSING
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS ONE OF THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITIES IN THE
NATION.
ARE WE'RE VERY PROUD OF WHAT OUR
MEMBERS TO YOU HERE -- AND WE
WOULD AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN SAID ABOUT ALLOWING
A MUCH EASIER ACCESS KNOWING
WHERE SITES ARE AVAILABLE A
NUMBER OF NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
ARE NOW EXPANDING.
OUTSIDE OF THEIR ORIGINAL
COMMUNITY AND LOOKING FOR SITES
IS VERY CHALLENGING IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO YOU KNOW YOUR JAMBOREE
HOUSING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND NOW YOU'RE EXPANDING IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO THIS.
THE DATABASE LIKE THIS AS AS
PETER SAID WILL SHAVE REALLY
VALUABLE TIME OFF OF THAT EFFORT --
AND MAKE IT EASIER TO AT LEAST
SECURE THE LAND THAT WE NEED
THANK YOU.
GREAT I ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS QUIRK SILVA -- MISTER BAILEY
JUST AYE IN HOUSING AND I
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS DOUBLE
REFERRED.
YES -- BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
TOPICS CROSS BOTH OF THEM
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I PARTICULARLY LIKE
ABOUT THIS BILL.
IS I HAVE BEEN ON ACCOUNT AMID
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE.
FOR LEAVE THIS IS MY FOURTH YEAR
AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE DON'T TAKE
TO KIND OF STREAMLINE AND SO
FORTH BUT OTHER TIMES -- WERE
FORCED TO AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL ALTHOUGH WE SAY IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL IT'S REALLY.
ON A MUCH MORE THAN THAT BECAUSE
OF ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW IS IT'S NOT JUST EACH
COMMUNITY OR EACH CITY.
OR COUNTY THAT IS NOW.
FORCED TO LOOK AT THIS A VERY
SERIOUS TOPIC OF A HOMELESS
CRISIS.
BUT IT'S ALSO ONCE WE PUT
FORWARD THE TOOLS WHETHER IT BE
WITH FUNDING WHETHER IT BE WITH --
VARIOUS TYPES OF GRANTS -- SO
FORTH IT'S ALSO GIVING THE TOOLS
TO THE LOCAL I. ENTITIES TO
NAVIGATE THEM AND THE MORE WORK
IT TAKES TO NAVIGATE WHETHER
IT'S FOR A GRANT WHETHER IT'S
DEFINED -- LAND THAT IS
AVAILABLE THAT JUST ADDS TIME
LET ALONE ALL THE OTHER BARRIERS
BUT AN EXAMPLE IS AND ONE OF
PARK THE MY AREA.
THEY ARE MOVING FORWARD ON A A
MERGING STATE SHELTER AND
BECAUSE THERE WAS QUITE A BIT OF
OUTCRY -- ONE OF THE WAYS THE
COUNCIL OF MOVE FORWARD WAS
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT THE
ORIGINAL SITE THEY HAD SHOWS AND
THEY ASK THE CITY MANAGER. TO
LOOK FOR ANOTHER SPOT.
THAT THE CITY OWNED AND WITHIN A
MEETING HE CAME BACK WITH A
PARCEL THAT.
REALLY WASN'T ON ANYBODY'S RADAR
THE PUBLIC WAS MUCH HAPPIER WITH
THAT.
AND NOW SUPPORT IT BECAUSE IT
WAS A PIECE OF LAND THAT REALLY
WAS ON ANYBODY SO RADAR SO I
BELIEVE THIS DATABASE WILL ALLOW
NOT ONLY LIKE YOU SAY DEVELOPERS
BUT THE PUBLIC.
COMMUNITIES LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
COUNTY AND GOING IN AND KIND OF
HAVE A MAP FOR NAVIGATION OF
WAIT WE REALLY DIDN'T EXPECT
THIS. FOUR YEARS AGO ON
ACCOUNTABILITY WE WERE ACTUALLY
DOING THE OPPOSITE OF THIS WE
WERE OF TRYING TO GET RID OF
LAND -- THAT WAS NOT USED IN THE
WAY IT WAS A ORIGINALLY A
DETERMINED CAMPS UP IN DIFFERENT
AREAS I KNOW IT WAS A ONE OF A
YOUTH CAMP IN OUR AREA IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WAS BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY SO I THINK THIS IS
A VERY.
BIG BILL NOT A LITTLE BILL SO I
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD.
I'M.
RECENTLY I HAD A MEETING WITH
LOS ANGELES CONTROLLER RUN
GIRLFRIEND AND HE HAS UNDERTAKEN
EXACTLY THIS WHERE THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND IT'S PROVING TO
BE A VERY USEFUL TOOL ALREADY SO.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE THIS EXPANDED
AND I WILL HAPPILY SECOND THE
BILL.
I WILL SIMPLY.
ADD THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS YOU SAID THERE IS NO
ONE SO FAR PAUL IT TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT THIS DOES
SEEM LIKE A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE SO SO THANK
YOU.
I WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES -- THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS -- I'M
EXCITED TO MAKE THIS BILL
WORKABLE THING TO SAVE MONEY AND
TIME AND DEVELOPING HOUSING AND
I THINK IT'S GONNA.
HELP THE LAND BANKERS THE
HOUSING LAND BANKERS.
KIND OF LIKE WE DO OPEN SPACE
YOU KNOW WE WE GO OUT WE BY THIS
OPEN SPACE WE HAVE OPEN SPACE
TRUST AND ALL THAT.
I THINK THIS WILL HELP OUR LAND
BANKERS FOR HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING
SAWYER CHEN AYE VOTE I THINK
IT'S A VERY PROGRESSIVE --
CONCEPT TO HAVE -- THE STATE
ALLOW THESE THINGS TO HAPPEN SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I SECRETARY FOR HIM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS I
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
LACKEY.
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA AYE QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE CEMENT
SMITH HI.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE JUST WAITING ON MISTER
DODD AND MISTER HERTZBERG
--
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
TWENTY THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR
AND IT.
BRITTANY SB TWENTY SB TWENTY
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO COUNTY THE
GO CHIC.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO BY THE OTHER.
SKYLINE WILL THAT IS PART.
OF PIECE OF LAND WITH POPULAR
HIKING TRAILS
.
THE STATE AUTHORIZED THE SALE
SKYLINE PARK TO THE COUNTY SO
THAT WOULD BUT FOR THE SAME
REASONS BUT THAT AUTHORIZATION --
EXPIRED -- IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SO IT'S CENTURY
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL YOU'RE
ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- CENTER
MENTION ASSOCIATED DIFFERENTLY
THERE SEVEN YEARS LEFT ON THE
EXISTING LAYS OUT SOME OF THE
MEMBERS TO KNOW.
SKYLINE PARK IS BETWEEN A QUARRY
AND A STATE MENTAL HEALTH
HOSPITAL AND SO -- YOU KNOW TO
THE DEGREE THIS COULD REALLY BE
SURPLUS IN THE THE VALUE OF IT --
WE JUST HAD A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE STATE WE LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO NEGOTIATE
SOMETHING AMENABLE TO ALL
PARTIES -- AND SO I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THE BILL.
AT ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LAURIE
TEN TOUGH AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
NAPA COUNTY.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL -- BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT NEED TO BE MADE --
WHICH WE HAVE SUBMITTED.
TO THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF MY NAME IS KATHY
FELL CHOI I'M A RESIDENT OF NAPA
COUNTY.
A CLOSE NEIGHBOR OF SKYLINE PARK
I'VE SPOKEN WITH MR DOT BEFORE
ABOUT SKYLINE PARK.
OF AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AND AN
HISTORIAN.
OF I SUPPORT THIS BILL -- ONLY
IF THERE ARE AMENDMENTS TO IT
WE'VE TRIED EVERY WHICH WAY TO
GET A LETTER TO YOU AND WE HOPE
YOU HAVE IT.
IF NOT I'M GOING TO LEAVE COPIES
FOR EACH MEMBER.
OF THE DESCRIBED HIM AMENDMENTS
WE NEED THAT WILL GUARANTEE.
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
WILL BE AFFECT TO HEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I'VE SEEN AND I KNOW I WE HAD A
A LENGTHY CONVERSATION EARLIER
ABOUT -- ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUE
SPELLS AROUND.
IT LANDED ENSURE AT THE YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS WAS
ENSURING THAT THE STATE IS
GETTING A FAIR RETURN FOR THE
LAND.
JUST TO CLARIFY IT THIS BILL IS
PERMISSIVE IN NATURE AND THERE
WILL BE A NEGOTIATION TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE'S INTERESTS ARE.
I PRESERVED CRISIS LIKE THE LOTS
OF THE FACT THAT WAS ON THAT
WERE SUPERVISORS LAST TIME AND
THEN THE MARKET RATE FOR THAT
PROPERTY I THINK AT THE TIME WAS
SOME LIKE THREE POINT SIX FIVE
WE JUST.
COULDN'T COME UP WITH THE MONEY
TO DO IT BY THE BY THE DATE SO
IT EXPIRED SO.
IT'S MOST DEFINITELY A FAIR
MARKET VALUE ARTS LIKE TRIMS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR FOR
CLARIFYING -- BUT THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE I LACKEY.
MEDINA MEDINA I CREEK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SMITH SMITH HI.
ALL RIGHT AT BELL IS OUT AND
DIVE.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND IF WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE AT IN READ
THROUGH THEM THE BELLS WE CAN
ENABLE OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
WITH ONE BELL ON CALL.
THAT IS AT SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR GLAZER FILE ITEM.
SIX BURKE BURKE I OKAY AND WITH
THAT THAT BELL IS OUT AND MOVES
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BURKE
BURKE I SB SIX BURKE BURKE I SB
THREE FORTY EIGHT BURKE.
BURKE I S. C. R. THIRTY ONE
BURKE BURKE I ALL RIGHT I
BELIEVE.
ALL RIGHT I WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPENS IN A MALL -- NUMBERS
TO ADD ON TO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
IN FOR FIVE MINUTES IF ANYONE
WANTS TO COME OUT ON
CAN YOU GO
AHEAD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SB TWENTY LACKEY.
LACKEY I ALRIGHT I AND WITH THAT
ARE THAT CONCLUDES THE MEETING
OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
WE ARE TURN